[موسيقى]
استقبلت السماء الملبدة بالغيوم والسماء القاتمة
ليفربول يوم الأحد قبل موجة من
أشعة الشمس ، الظروف المختلطة التي
تتطابق مع المشاعر الحلوة والمرة
لمشجعي ليفربول عندما خرجوا بقوة
لاستعراض النصر ، تم الإعلان عن العرض
في منتصف مايو بعد أن فاز ليفربول بالفعل
باللقب.  كأس الدوري وكأس الاتحاد الإنجليزي مع
النادي لا يزال في طريقه لتحقيق رباعي تاريخي ،
لكن هوامش
كرة القدم والرياضة غالبًا ما تكون ضعيفة ،
فاز الحمر بهذه الكؤوس بركلات الترجيح
التي خسروها في الدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز بنقطة إلى جانب الهزيمة في
دوري أبطال أوروبا يوم السبت  نهائي
بهدف واحد ، تم ترك العديد من المعجبين
يتأملون ما كان يمكن أن يكون
هو أنه كان محبطًا حقًا
، وخاصة أننا لم نتغلب على
حسرة الأسبوع الماضي أيضًا ،
لذا كان الأمر صعبًا حقًا ولكن أعتقد أن
هذا العرض قد أعطانا الآن  شيء
نتطلع إليه
ولتذكيرنا فقط كم نحن محظوظون لأن نكون من
مشجعي ليفربول ، اعتقدنا أنه سيكون
أربعة وأربعة ولكن هذا للأسف فقط.  لا بأس ،
إنها اثنتان فقط
ولكن
اثنان أفضل من ذلك الحين ،
أشعر وكأنني القشة وأنا سعيد على الرغم من
أننا فزنا بكأسين
لعبنا جميع المباريات التي كان بإمكاننا
لعبها بأفضل ما لدينا ،
لكنك تعلم أننا حصلنا في الموسم المقبل على كل أربعة
و  سيعود هؤلاء المشجعون للتجذير في
ليفربول الموسم المقبل الرباعي
في مرآة الرؤية الخلفية وفي المرة الأخيرة
التي خسروا فيها نهائي دوري الأبطال في
2018 فازوا بها في العام التالي في عام
2019 وسيُقام نهائي دوري أبطال أوروبا العام المقبل
فقط في  أسلوب
على الرغم من العودة الضخمة ضد
ميلان في عام 2005. هذا الموسم سوف يستغرق
المزيد من الهضم قبل
أن يعود الرجال المعجزون مرة أخرى في أغسطس
[موسيقى]